intel finally dropped their mobile alder  lake chips in the form of the msi raider  ge76  and it is impressive let's go ahead and  dig right in and see can this emerald  max hang in there with this big boy now  as far as price it comes in at four  thousand  dollars the m1 pro and max ship finally  gets beat now looking at multi-core once  again it gets beat in order to achieve  this performance one we have this huge  laptop with a crazy uh cooling system  and it actually has to cool up to about  120 watts of power and now let's talk  about the graphics card this thing can  actually use up to  175 watts of power compared to the m1  max's up to 46 peak not a really big  difference there compared to the  difference in wattage and fan noise  overall we see that the performance of  these cpus are incredible